du jamais vu dans l'histoire de la
première économie du continent africain
le produit intérieur brut de l'afrique
du sud s'est effondré de 51% en deuxième
trimestre une récession sans précédent
qui frappe un pays déjà durement éprouvé
par la situation sanitaire
l'afrique du sud compte le plus grand
nombre de victimes du coc vite 19 sur le
continent africain avec quelques quinze
mille morts à ce jour le 27 mars dernier
afin de freiner la propagation du
coronavirus le gouvernement sud-africain
mettait en place un confinement strict
de huit semaines en limitant les
déplacements de la population au
détriment des activités économiques
conséquence directe l'effondrement du
pib en grande partie due au fort recul
des secteurs de la construction de
l'industrie manufacturière et de
l'exploitation minière
trois secteurs qui accuse une baisse
d'activité de plus de 70%
leader de la production minière avec les
trois quarts de la production mondiale
et deuxième pays producteur d'or au
monde l'afrique du sud regorge de
ressources naturelles mais voit ses
exportations sombré depuis le début de
la pandémie avec un chômage de masse et
un état qui n'a plus d'argent les
inégalités sociales dans le pays ne
cesse de croître
selon le programme des nations unies
pour le développement l'extrême pauvreté
pourrait y bondir de plus de 60% dans
les prochains mois après la crise
sanitaire
une crise sociale majeure est d'ores et
déjà en train de frapper les sud
africains dans un récent rapport la
banque mondiale décrit l'afrique du sud
comme le pays le plus inégalitaire au
monde